let's be real Steven Spielberg has very
few movies to talk badly about but
according to him there is something in
Close Encounters of the Third Kind that
he really wishes he'd cut one of the
coolest things about the movie is the
aliens they're pretty ambiguous for the
majority of the film and it wasn't
really until the end that they were
really seen like at all there's one
scene in particular where Steven
Spielberg shoots inside the mothership
going through the entirety of its
interior he actually hated that he did
that because he thought it ruined the
Allure of the aliens he actually ended
up cutting it from the theatrical
release as far as CGI is concerned this
movie was filmed before it was a huge
thing in the industry but they did do
some Stellar special effects Artistry
inside the mothership again this was a
major bummer to Spielberg he hated using
all the special effects and wished he'd
cut it from the movie entirely